il est 7h45 ce lundi alors que certaines
démarrent leur journée d'autres la
termine tout juste c'est l'heure des
transmissions alors avant de se réunir
les transmissions d'informations se font
d'abord autres auxiliaires
puéricultrices d'un côté et sages femmes
de l'autre salle de consultation numéro
deux de cette façon une demi-heure très
complémentaires les sages-femmes et les
auxiliaires ont des rôles étroitement
liés l'auxiliaire se définit comme les
petites mandat sage femme
si le médecin n'est pas là lors d'un
accouchement c'est elle qui l'assistent
après l'accouchement elles se chargent
des premiers soins du bébé
et tout cela toujours sous la
responsabilité de la sage femme
si vous avez l'habitude de toujours
travailler avec la même et que celle ci
en plus connaît vos gestes anticipe vos
gestes sur une animation où il faut
aller très vite bien au lieu de lui dire
je voudrais ça en fait elle m'avoue le
mettre dans la main et donc du coup va
vous gagnez les des minutes des ombres
est très important pour un bébé
sylvie est arrivé ici il y a cinq ans ce
qu'il a notamment poussé à se lancer
dans ce métier c'est son goût pour
l'urgence se tenir prête à tout moment
le rôle de la sage-femme est complexe
elle s'occupe davantage de la maman
avant pendant et après l'accouchement
ce matin-là attrape les sages femmes
font leur traditionnelle visite de
suites de couches mouais mais comme la
contraction est froid je vous ai apporté
justement du spasme des données la
sage-femme veille au bien-être physique
mais aussi psychologique de la maman un
petit examen chaque jour enfin pour
vérifier que voilà y'a pas de saignement
que tout va bien tout se remet bien en
place c'est aussi beaucoup de
relationnel à ce moment là parce que
c'est là qu'elles ont besoin
qu'on les aide qu'on les épaules il faut
énormément observé aimait les gens
parce que pour les observer il faut
vraiment lésés mais voilà avoir envie de
partager quelque chose avec avec un
couple des situations très agréable les
situation très désagréable la mort d'un
bébé la banque drôme un bébé des choses
comme ça et puis il faut après être très
professionnel c'est à dire qu'on a un
métier qui a une grosse responsabilité
donc il faut toujours toujours se
remettre en question bonjour madame a
sonné au sein la pâte filo celle
auxiliaires kg m'occuper de vous
aujourd'hui
bonjour mademoiselle lucie bon appétit
9h25
place aux premiers bains du bébé avec
philomène auxiliaire puéricultrice
cette maman vient d'accoucher de son
troisième enfant et ressent le besoin
d'avoir quelques rappels la priorité
elle est quand même dans la sécurité 1
nous on a un rôle de probant dire deux
conseillères on est pas on va pas aller
chez elle mais par contre il faut mettre
le point
où c'est nécessaire à mon sens on y va
comment maintenir une eau à bonne
température quels sont les bons gestes
et les bons réflexes pour garder la bd
en sécurité philomène apporte toutes les
réponses
ce premier bain est aussi l'occasion de
vérifier que tout va bien pour le bébé
que tout seul du 6,3 kg 40 alors la
possession pour être en sécurité
tu m'aides aujourd'hui si on est sympa
la voix la fin de la matinée
les collègues se retrouvent pour une
pause-café un moment privilégié
ça nous arrive quand même de parler de
certaines patientes ou bébé mais souvent
c'est plutôt voilà on se parle de les
choses perso appliquant malgré un rythme
difficile des horaires de jour comme de
nuit ainsi que les jours fériés ou
encore les week-ends ces femmes n'en
perd pas moins leur sourire et leur
bonheur